[Music]
welcome to sophie
visionaries me selfie showing offset
they call it 19
pandemic has cut us all off guard as
individuals
and as humanity what are the lessons
that we can all draw from all this want
to discuss it i'm joined by a true
spiritual rock star yogi and mystic
visionary author
some guru it's so great to have you with
us
three years on namaskaram sophie i think
it's
nearly two and a half years since i saw
you last time in saint petersburg
and and we had quite a discussion in uh
saint peter's work on the
international economic forum then but
wow
now during the pandemics what a time to
really rethink and re-evaluate
everything in life
so i'm just going to go straight in and
ask you that the world
right now is somewhat divided over the
cobit 19 pandemic
there are some that say that it's just
another pandemic pandemics like this
occur once in every century for humanity
to
sort of purify itself then there are
others who really believe that this
pandemic is
some sort of a lesson to teach us uh
and to sort of make us reconsider our
future as
species where do you stand
well uh if your neighbor dies
maybe you think it's purification or a
lesson to learn
but if you die or your children die or
somebody dear to you dies
i don't think you will think this is a
lesson or purification that's a very
cruel way of looking at life
yes pandemics have happened in the past
but
the level of ignorance we were at that
time the last big one was the spanish
flu
but just after world war one at that
time what would uh what was our
knowledge about
uh you know these pathogens and our
ability to control
it no antibiotics and today we have all
this
in spite of that we are little out of
control simply because uh
we have not become conscious enough all
this takes
is because human beings are the carriers
if you and me behave consciously
as we are see you're out there i'm here
no way to infect each other if
everybody maintains because human being
is the carrier
all you have to do do is some amount of
distancing for a period of time it would
have just died down
but not every human being is either
responsible or conscious about it
so it's very important if we really want
to take care of this
because world's population has increased
so much the proximity of human beings is
very high today
so and people are traveling air travel
takes people all over the world so
because of this
it is very important that we create a
conscious planet that human beings
are conscious about what they do right
now
people are thinking pitching for their
compulsive behavior is their freedom
uh somebody wants to drink somebody
wants to have a haircut
so they want to go out it doesn't matter
what happens to your neighbor
what happens to the older people in the
society
your your parents or your grandparents
who are beyond a certain age and they
are vulnerable
and other people who have gone through
organ transplants and various other
cardiac and other conditions who are
vulnerable to the virus
and they for them it could be fatal not
being concerned about
uh the age population and the vulnerable
population
is a very serious concern because
human beings are supposed to be a little
more concerned about each other
than just saying this is purification
somebody else is dying
and this is purification no no that's a
terrible thing to say
so you're saying awareness is the most
important thing in all of this and
you've also said that
humanity has never been so well equipped
uh
to to battle something of this scale but
isn't it ironic in a way that we humans
we're talking about
colonizing mars and we're talking about
singularity
and the evolution has you know sort of
jump started and the technical
revolution is
so uh far beyond like anything that we
could have imagined 10 years ago and yet
when this pandemic hit we're battling it
pretty much in the same way as we were
battling
the spanish 100 years ago just by
sitting at home
and not socializing
not really 100 years ago spanish flu
killed over 50 million people i don't
think such a thing will happen today
and about colonizing mars well if you
want to ruin this planet and go to
another one
that's a very sad way to live
it's very important that uh
it's a privilege of a human being that
we can
function consciously that means we can
function
beyond our natural instincts every other
creature on the planet
functions within its natural instincts
but a human being can function beyond
our natural
instincts that is the significance of
being human
that means we have to be conscious so if
this consciousness is something that we
do not display
well it amounts to evolutionary issues
within ourselves
because all other creatures are always
function within the parameters of their
own
instinctual you know set up within them
we can function beyond that and as you
mentioned that
there is so much development there is so
much medical science there is so much
knowledge
but still people are pitching for their
compulsion one of the most
significant revelations that came to me
during this pandemic was that
many uh tangible materialistic things
that we used to
want don't really matter that much
anymore um
and the things that i'm craving right
now are really just very simple things
human contact
freedom of choice uh where to go after
this is over you know
do you think once the lockdowns are
lifted and the pandemic
is over this ceiling will stay with us
or we'll be back to
all the greed and consumerism
uh it depends how long this virus will
trouble us suppose uh in the next two
months
let's say before august september if
it's gone
probably in another three to four months
everybody will be back to their usual
stuff
but suppose the virus trouble lasts for
us uh
let's say nine to 12 months then
a certain percentage of people will
transform themselves
suppose the virus stays on for 24 to 36
months let's say
it is remote but if such a thing happens
that
you know waves on second third waves if
they keep coming and taking people's
lives
then i think a significant percentage of
human population will change their
behavior for sure
so it's really unfortunate a
microorganism
with a millionth of our brain has to
teach us a lesson
and we have to transform ourselves
because a virus comes and threatens our
life
it is the beauty of being human being
that
we can sit here look at various aspects
we've been given the intelligence and
the
consciousness to sit here and transform
ourselves
before any calamity happens to us this
is how a human being should be
but unfortunately we need to be
threatened
to transform um so i suppose
um whether we come out of this crisis
with a clear
idea of who we really are and what we
need like you're saying
depends on how long the pandemic will
last
i was speaking maybe two weeks ago with
a french writer and philosopher bernard
berber
and he told me that humans are bad
students
that we would need more devastating
lessons like this one to learn something
i certainly hope that's not the case
what do you think
well that's what i'm saying as long as
somebody else's life is being taken
you can philosophize but if it comes to
your life i think all philosophies will
evaporate
you will want to survive so right now
instead of going on weaving and spinning
these philosophies
everybody maintain social distance and
stay alive for this period
after that we can look at all this
philosophies we can weave
as many as we want but the important
thing is
life happens in a certain way are we in
tune with it or not
is the only question when i say life
happens in a certain way
this our life is not a separate
existence on this planet
every moment that we breathe and every
moment that we exist here there's a
whole lot of
transaction happening so virus bacteria
are all very much a part of us
this particular virus
which was living in animals has now
jumped into human beings for whatever
reason
is mainly one reason you could say is
their habitat
the animal habitat is sinking you know
shrinking so
rapidly in the sense uh from 1970 to now
in 50 years time nearly uh
60 of the vertebrate population is gone
so where will the virus go it has to
find some new terrain so it has found us
well this keeps happening often there
are various factors
which cause this but the important thing
is
as human beings we are calling ourselves
beings
see we don't call any other creature on
this planet as a being
we don't call a tiger being or a buffalo
being or an ant being or anything like
this
we call only this one as human being
because we are supposed to know how to
be
if we know how to be we would keep
ourselves very conscious
conscious means if there was a choice
right now
for yourself or for any other human
being whether right now
to be joyful blissful or miserable and
frustrated
what would you choose definitely the
highest level of pleasantness for
yourself
so people do not know how to be
that is the main problem otherwise these
are all natural things happening
this is not a calamity i'm saying this
is not really a calamity
but we human beings are making it into
your calamity
virus bacteria has come and gone we have
managed we have integrated all this
into our system at various levels these
viruses in the past have also caused
significant mutations and develop you
know evolutionary processes within our
cells so it is not all negative but
right now this uh virus is not being
carried by either mosquitoes or
mice or some other animal no we are the
carriers
all we have to do is you and me like we
are doing
wonderfully well right now we keep some
distance
this is it virus is over
we're going to take a short break right
now when we're back we'll continue
talking about what are the lessons to be
drawn
from the covenant 19th pandemic for us
as individuals
and as humanity stay with us
and we're back with sound guru
like you're saying we're the only beings
that call ourselves beings
and how to know to be is the most
important thing
the problem with that is that most of
the people when they're not
locked down or in self-isolation don't
really think about how to be
because you know you're caught up in a
process you live in a big city you live
in a big country you're busy you don't
really think how to be you you just
are and now an amazing amount of people
find themselves in self-isolation and
it's almost like
they have no other choice than to ponder
upon how to be and about that way to be
i found myself thinking about things
that i didn't want to think about for
the longest time you know like it's not
always pleasant to think about your
fears
or you know your problems uh or your
doubts and then
you're facing them because you're alone
in self-isolation and
from that comes the sense of really
knowing how to be
and it took some quiet space and quiet
time to
to sort of come to this what do you
think as
paradoxical as it may sound do you feel
like in a way
with humans in self-isolation have
maybe gotten closer to understanding
what it is that way to be for us
uh i wouldn't make uh such a
what to say a very generous conclusion
because i have i live with reality i am
not in a hallucinatory state to imagine
everybody is coming into their being
no maybe some of them are coming to
terms with their own psychological mess
first mistake is people are mistaking
their psychological drama
as life see what happens in your mind is
your drama
your thought your emotion is all made by
you
but people think this itself is life
most human beings unfortunately are
under that misunderstanding
that their physiological and
psychological drama is everything
these are two things you must conduct
properly but both these things are not
conducted properly
because everything is happening this
psychological drama going crazy
badly directed psychological drama is
creating a mess
out of people now coming to terms with
your psychological mass
is not being all right being means
that you are a being as a you because
you are capable of existing you're
capable of being conscious about your
existence
so you are a being so it's not something
that you have to
invent or create it is already there
all you have to do is you must bring a
little bit of distance
from your physiological and
psychological drama
what you call as our mind is just a heap
of impressions that we have gathered
what we gather can be ours can never be
us
this is this belongs to us but this is
not us
all the time it is going through
transition all the time things are
changing within body
what was yesterday a part of this body
today it is not
what is what was not your body yesterday
is today is a part of this body
so this is going on and the same thing
is true with your mind
so what you accumulate the moment you
mistake your
that to be you then the madness is
started
this madness they're trying to fix with
religion with philosophy
with ideologies it's not going to work
because
all you will do is try to adjust the
madness you cannot adjust the madness
you have to distance yourself from the
madness
so you are about to ask how do you do
that there are simple ways to do
this well right now across the world
millions of people are practicing what
is called as a simple process called
isha kriya with which you can make a
distance between yourself
and what you have accumulated your body
and your mind right now for all the
people
medical personnel who are fighting this
virus across the world
we have offered in engineering online
free of cost to all of them
and for everybody else we brought it
down to a 50
cost for the whole world because we know
at this time
everybody is trying to deal with
themselves which is a big problem look
at this
outside if you have problems in the
world it's okay but you yourself are a
problem this is a
serious problem isn't it in our life
variety of problems are there in the
world we have to face it
but if we ourselves my own thought my
own emotion is a big problem
then there is a solution whatever
solution you think of
is going to be more problems this is
what is happening to the world
because a problematic mind a compulsive
mind
with which with this they are trying to
find solutions
no solutions will come you will only
complicate the problems more and more
because problem itself the source of
problem right now
is just in the way we think and feel
if the viruses come and we know
that it is there and we could transmit
it to each other
what is our problem just to close our
eyes and sit for 15 days 14 days is all
you have to sit
if you sit for 14 days alone virus is
gone out of this planet
um i suppose you partially answered my
next question but i'm gonna
try to paraphrase it in a way because
this crisis
um yes has made us reconsider many
things but also
um sort of full-length all the
abscesses of our society all the
downfalls of humanity human nature
um and maybe some are becoming more
conscious but a lot of us are becoming
more paranoid you know we have this
psychotic
xenophobic uh feelings in us this fear
of the unknown and like you said for
instance like
probably in the near future i'm not
gonna be shaking hands with anyone
even when the pandemic is over you know
i'm not sure
that i will be flying we've been doing
this all the time
[Laughter]
so so it has also brought this fear
of the other in us this whole pandemic
when you're saying that you need to
separate who you are
your being and your problems that you've
accumulated does that work
in this particular case as well where
this is like an
all-around fear that you fear a
foreigner coming to your country because
he's going to bring
kobe 19. you fear a neighbor approaching
your
house because you don't know if he has
covered 19 or not
how to deal with that fear the same way
say uh caution is one thing fear is
another thing
caution is in terms of action all right
it is in terms of action taking
preventive or preemptive action
about whatever else right now if you're
driving a car
let's say there was an elephant on the
road or that doesn't happen in russia it
happens in india okay
we have white bears i'm kidding
or let's say a bear came on the road you
will apply bricks
before you hit it the best time to apply
brakes is well before you hit it right
so if you apply brakes do you have to
necessarily do it out of fear
no you can just break efficiently
that's that's just avoiding a problem
all right right now similarly
there is no elephant it's not that big
it's a
microscopic virus we just have to apply
breaks
where is the need for fear fear is
happening because
see there are two basic faculties in a
human being
which sets us apart significantly from
other creatures
one is we have a vivid sense of memory
and a fantastic sense of imagination
right now these two wonderful faculties
is what human beings are largely
suffering
what happened 10 years ago they are
still suffering
what may happen day after tomorrow they
are already suffering
no no they are not suffering life they
are just suffering their own memory and
their own imagination
so the problem is great faculties that
you
that have been given to you to arrive at
these faculties through evolutionary
process
it took millions of years of evolution
to get to this place
of cerebral activity and now it's become
a mess
how how great is that i'm asking it took
millions of years of work to give you
this big brain which functions with this
many
capabilities now most human beings are
suffering what is a magnificent machine
human beings have turned into a misery
manufacturing machine
that's what needs to change how we
handle our own body
our own mind this fundamental has to
change
right now we think it's our right to
suffer
well you have right to suffer you have
to right to die also
but is that the point because life is
such a brief happening
if you start exploring human potential
even if you live to be hundred years
it is too brief a life all right
we are here with just for a brief amount
of time how much mess out of that
endless amount of mess virus comes one
problem virus doesn't come another
problem
endlessly problem only you tell me what
is it that's a problem not a problem in
human life
toddlers have diaper problems
adolescents have hormone problems middle
age is a crisis
old age is horrible death is terrible
what is not a problem
everything is a problem no nothing is a
problem
there are situations and situations in
your mind
if you want to make something into your
problem you can make
just about anything into your problem
or you can look at a situation as a
situation and do the best that you can
do in the given situation
um sakura you have also said that kovind
19 has made
us conscious of our mortality
and that made me think i mean
we have more reason to fear deaths than
usual because we fear deaths
always there are a lot of other things
that can kill you
other than calling 19.
we have always been mortal though a
whole lot of people
go about in their life as if they're
immortal
most people think other people die
no you and me will die i'll bless you
with a long life but we will die
so it is just that the virus
has brought it up front in our faces
that you're mortal
it's silly that a little virus a
minuscule virus has to teach us this
lesson every human being must know
that we are mortal being mortal what it
means is
that means we have a limited amount of
time if
every moment of our life we were
conscious that we are mortal
we would not have time to do anything
that does not mean much to us
we would do what really matters to us if
all human beings if you and me
are doing what truly matters to us this
becomes a beautiful world
right now a whole lot of people are
doing absolute rubbish which doesn't
mean a damn thing to them or to anybody
but they keep doing it out of their
compulsiveness so it's important to get
humanity
to a place where everybody is doing what
truly genuinely matters to them
they don't have to do what matters to me
or to you
they must do what genuinely matters to
their life
if you are doing what matters to your
life i am doing what matters to my life
believe me what you do and what i do
will not be very different
right now we are going by the quirkiness
of
one's mind not by the needs of our life
well i think it's another interview to
figure out
what is it that we need for our life but
i really thank you for these wise words
for your insight for your thoughts um i
think these are much
needed words and thoughts that people
need to hear right now during
strange times i really hope that we meet
again
rather sooner or later you get the you
get the virus out of russia
i will come and see you okay stay safe
you